it is StayWell Wednesday sponsored by
Optum care and today we're talking about
stress how does it affect your overall
health and how do we manage it we are
really happy to have Dr Arlene rillo a
VIP Primary Care a contracted provider
for Optum Care Network Nevada welcome
thank you it's my pleasure to be here I
am so excited to talk to you because we
all suffer from stress correct it's
something that I feel like you can't
really avoid and what what are signs
that you are a truly stressed person
well like what you said like every you
know stress is a part of everyday life
you know it can not all stress it's bad
like sometimes it could work for us
especially the short-lived ones it can
trigger us to finish tasks but the
problem is when stress becomes chronic
and becomes overwhelming it does impact
our health it affects various organ
systems like increases our heart rate
blood pressure so you know it causes a
lot of problem Beyond just emotional and
mental physical as well that's
interesting and I think we've all seen
the effects of it when we've been
stressed out but that's not the only
emotion under this umbrella that can
affect our health what are some of the
other feelings well when you know
somebody is stressed and it can increase
their anxiety and when they're anxious
it can lead you to not perform well or
have relationship problems then can
snowball into depression so and it also
has physical symptoms so you know signs
and symptoms that you may be stressed if
you're having this unexplained fatigue
headache suddenly you're like you know
easily triggered irritable or worsening
of otherwise stable chronic condition or
increasing use or start of use of
substances like Alcohol Tobacco as a way
to cope you know well not in a healthy
way unfortunately what we only have a
few seconds left but I have to ask you I
know it's not a one-size-fits all but
what can we do to combat it well to
combat it it's like you know first
taking the active staff in reducing
stress there are techniques like
relaxation techniques meditation yoga
just ensuring you are eating
well-balanced diet exercise exercise
releases feel good hormones the
endorphins so you sleep better as well
and it's also good for cardiovascular
and if you are really stressed and it's
feeling very overwhelmed calling our
your providers you can start with
calling your primary care physician and
then we can talk about specific
therapies that's appropriate for you we
can even talk about medication if it's
needed and also it can trigger a
referral to our friendly mental health
specialist to help us with the anxiety
and stress I love it such I feel less
stressed after talking to you thank you
so much for the great information and
care for sponsoring this segment they
have several locations across Southern
Nevada for more information visit
optumcare.com forward slash Nevada